so now when I see these people I just go
hey how you doing what's up it's good to
see you you know a little small talk but
then that's it I get it now I tell you
the most hurtful thing that ever
happened what's that
so arm when I was on that TV my second
year I was having a hard time they
weren't using me a lot I didn't think
people liked me on the show but you know
like people would say stuff like it's in
your head
well that's a lot of that true though I
know still do that today I know but this
wasn't okay okay but the boy who cried
wolf you know so one day
oh great parallels very good go [ __ ]
yourself okay so one day I call Ike
Barinholtz and I go hey what'd you do
this weekend we're all up in Sonoma and
I go oh whoo the whole cast of MADtv
maybe it was an oversight no there was
an oversight the whole cast and I go
yeah Mike didn't invite you and dude I
[ __ ] cried so hard
it destroyed [ __ ] destroyed me man
so I get what you're saying yeah yeah so
that's why I know I so now it's actually
helped me so when I walk around now I go
to the improv the Laugh Factory I go to
the Comedy Store I see people and I just
go I know now I go oh this is like
Jeremiah I was till I sense Jeremiah
he's getting married I love him and I
was telling him we were having a
conversation about this and then then
like later he hit me up he's like what's
your address man I was like I said no
ma'am what's your pity invite
oh yeah I'm gonna go yeah life event
yeah but you know but it's okay cuz we
the problem is is comedy it's so
emotional and it's so like you're like I
want your birthday party that was great
yeah you surprised one that you went
ahead yeah well you didn't go why would
you say that I didn't go because I'm
trying to help you out I know I did
because you know yeah if you would've
invited me I would've gone would have
been different yeah yeah
but no but I'm saying like it's like you
just have to like now you know you just
like okay here's a people I like
whatever yeah but let me just say if you
see Sebastian Maniscalco huh do you say
hi yeah you talk yeah I talk to people
there's a little something just a little
bit I love that I know we're friends not
really friends it's cool listen think
I'm not mad about the [ __ ] I'm really
not it's just like now you know because
I'm like a I feel like I'm very
personable so I got my meet yeah I'm
like oh [ __ ] and I realized I can't do
that you can't just do that just because
you work with someone even cuz you
travel with them how many times have you
been on like you working on a show and
like you're not you're hanging with the
crew and you're hanging with people in
your trailer and everybody's laughing
the day that [ __ ] wraps you're never you
never see this [ __ ] again I know
I hate this just like that it's just a
long summer camp that might be a
blessing though because I have a Korean
girl friend of mine and all her church
friends are legit her friends she's gone
to like 16 weddings this year it's
exhausting when I look at her I geez
stories I'm like [ __ ] no I don't want
that [ __ ] like if you guys have a
destination wedding I'm gonna kill you
both well you're still you wouldn't come
to that and we'd be offended me Bobby's
gonna pay right no I will probably be in
LA yeah of course it'll be enough oh you
it's decided
yeah I have a say yeah coming come on
but that was planning the podcast and
planned away that raises a more serious
question is when you were talking about
that I was thinking to myself do I do I
have friends I know that's another
ultimate question like well do you don't
need a litter if you don't you shouldn't
have like you're right
cuz you can't give them all the time
they desert right